one of the best morning routines I can I
can recommend to any person on earth is
that you wake up and you decrease the
time between when you wake up and when
you start working we have a bunch of
buddies mutal that have exited companies
for hundreds of millions of dollars and
then they get like really obsessed with
their health and they have these massive
morning routines and they just get upset
you know all these supplements and red
lights on us and everyone who's watching
says oh this person's successful this is
what they do I should do that but what
got them there is not what they're doing
now right so it's like you want to model
the rise and so a lot of times the rise
is a lot of balance they're absolutely
trade-offs and it's just whether or not
you're willing to pay the price for it
if the Nikes that you want on the wall
are $500 that is the price you can just
choose to pay it or not but if you
choose to pay the $500 for the Nikes you
don't then say this was unhealthy you
just make the trade that's where a lot
of people spend all this time analyzing
themselves like feeling about their
feelings thinking about their thoughts
rather than just executing